what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so this is like one of the best
stories ever Batman gets a bachelor
party and I and I love this I love this
thing so much okay for those you guys
don't know Batman marrying Catwoman is
like the biggest moment in the history
of the Batman mythos right like DC's
been dancing around this for ever and
ever and ever and ever right it's always
been like oh you know it's like the Jim
and Pam situation will they won't they
that kind of a thing ultimately we know
what's gonna go in that direction now if
I'm a betting man all right I will bet
all the money in my pockets - all the
money in your pockets that marriage
ain't gonna work out something's gonna
happen something's gonna happen and
Batman uh-oh I laugh about this
Batman's misery is hilarious so so
something's gonna happen and like Batman
is gonna have to make a choice Bruce is
gonna have to make a choice between
staying married or being Batman and he's
gonna choose to be Batman either that or
Catwoman's gonna die but like
something's gonna happen I mean you know
it is Batman can't be happy you guys
know it's true like like you guys know
you guys know but this is amazed when
any way initially this picks up with
Superman in Knightley it's kind of funny
because they end up going to a place
called bat burger which I imagine has
like the most amazing food but like
everybody's dressed as superheroes let
me tell you something man I would go to
a restaurant with that was like
superhero themed like you all do I would
crush that place I'd make a great big
huge thing out of it like I would I'd
livestream it like I'd periscope it or I
would I would make a vlog out of it like
me a comic store Ian and sallekhana pop
like we would all like get together we
would fly out to that city and go to
that place and be like hey everybody
we're doing a fan meetup and like
whatever this restaurant is it's like a
superhero theme and all the care all the
the the employees are dressed as
superheroes you got condiment man back
there which I think it is actually the
real condiment man those you guys don't
know who condiment man is he's like the
greatest character ever he just like
runs up on folks with like ketchup and
mustard just start spraying him down
it's it's it's amazing it's pretty
awesome but this is also really touching
too because when you watch how Batman
interacts it's kind of funny because
this whole idea of him basically
marrying Catwoman it's like Batman
finally finding love right it's like the
one thing Batman can't have he can have
anything in the world that he wants
because of all the money he has but he
can't buy love and so because of that
Batman's always just kind of in the
situation where he's always brooding and
miserable that's how I'm probably cuz
he's never getting laid and then in
response to this you have like Batman
and Nightwing who show up and they're
like hey man we're here to whisk you off
your bachelor party and Batman's not
brooding he's smiling like
excited about he's like yeah man a
bachelor party a bachelor party a bat a
bat chiller party so anyway the cool
thing about this is that it's it's it's
what you would expect with a
superhero-themed bachelor party right
like I mean they kind of make a joke
about getting Batman strippers which I
would say it'd be kind of cool I heard
someone is having a special day you know
like like some chick comes in you know
and like just starts dance all over
Batman she's like let's remove that
itchy mask you just like get out of here
you know just are screaming I don't like
Batman would so do that yeah anyway
what's your man does is he actually
gives Batman like this kind of lightning
dork which allows him to access
different dimensions and this is so
genius and it's so cool because instead
of saying like hey man I don't want to
take you to an alternate universe called
flashpoint where your dad is Batman like
like I don't I mean instead of doing
that it's like hey we're just gonna go
fishing in this place like we're just
gonna go to like this pocket dimension
it's an infinite supply fish who knows
where they come from and where does
where it's gonna go fishing the problem
with this is that in the middle of it
all they're met by the arrival of hush
now Tommy's a character that we've never
really talked about hush has always been
one of the coolest characters in in DC
Comics when it comes to Batman and the
reason why is because it was it was
written by Jeph Loeb and drawn by by Jim
Lee it came out 2003 but hush was like
this great big storyline that served one
purpose to kind of add a little bit of
mythos in terms of how Batman became
Batman but then there's other things in
terms of like his back his back life
right like if you go and read Batman
year one by Frank Miller from you know
post-crisis 1988 or 1987 where it was it
came out you get this whole idea that
Bruce Wayne's parents died and then he
just kind of went headlong into like
studying all these forms of you know
knowledge and experience and gaining
martial arts and you know becoming a
weapons master and almost kind of all
kind of good stuff and it's cool for the
purpose that it serves but at the same
time what what hush did is it actually
introduced Tommy and it said that Tommy
was this kid that Bruce Wayne played
with when he was younger and it was
Thomas Eliot who basically taught him
things like you have to think from your
enemies perspective you don't play the
game you play the person and so that's
that's the whole thing that Thomas
Eliana Tommy was really kind of coming
from the idea was that Tommy wanted the
life of Bruce Wayne Conan quotient since
that Tommy came from a wealthy family
his father was extremely abusive in rim
really abuses mom but the idea was to
take them both out so that Tommy would
inherit basically his entire family's
fortune the result was that where he
essentially sabotages his parents cart
and his mom survived Bruce Wayne's
parents died and so following that Tommy
always kind of had this irrational
hatred
Bruce in a sense it was like Bruce took
the life of Tommy now this whole thing
is kind of interesting because it like
hush is probably one of the most notable
villains now he's not nearly as popular
as the Joker right and it's never really
been that way but he always wears
bandages over his face is his skill and
you know in plastic surgery different
things like that but for certain circles
for people who are more experienced with
Batman there's a lot of people out there
who will say hush is the most
interesting villain he has but what you
end up having is Nightwing who
immediately leaps into action and the
reason why is because Batman you know of
course saves Nightwing is life but it's
a way to just kind of throw the story in
that direction and this is kind of cool
because you don't really see Dick
Grayson fighting against hush you don't
really see it that often Hesh is a
Batman villain but still like in
response to all this like a Nightwing in
an Tommy actually end up flying through
the through the the the Lightning portal
more or less and the result is that
they're kind of thrown into this other
dimension but they actually kind of end
up in this place in the in-between which
is kind of between existence and
non-existence which is really kind of
weird because they're met with a guy and
is interesting because Deezy kind of
plays in this idea that he could be a
couple different people some will say
he's like the Phantom Stranger or some
might say that he's like the question or
something like that where you never see
his face you're never really given an
answer to the identity of this person
now it may be this is just designed to
be that way it's just a one-off and you
never really know who they are or it
could be that later on down the line
they play a bigger role
honestly I'd say it's probably the
former we're basically told this is the
place where like the echoes of men go
more or less when they've effectively
given up on life but some people are
yanked there there's some people have
pulled there against their own volition
but no matter what it is it goes on the
people who occupy this place are people
who basically don't have an identity
there's people who don't really know who
they are they've lost all sense of self
and so anyone who stumbles into their
path basically is taken by these
individuals what it requires is for
Tommy and Nightwing to fight side by
side and this is done for a reason one
of the things that's very easy to lose
track of when it comes to Tommy is that
he's a very capable fighter he's very
much a thinking man's villain and so
when you have someone like Nightwing
it's really the half-life effect right
Lee you can only ever create something
that's half what you are when it comes
to Bruce Wayne taking Tim drag or I'm
sorry taking you out Dick Grayson under
his wing and then teaching him to become
Nightwing or become Robin and then
eventually Nightwing Dick Grayson will
never be Bruce Wayne he'll only ever be
half of what Bruce Wayne is you only
ever be half the man because that's the
way things play out but with Dick
Grayson and Tommy working you know
working alongside each other it's
actually pretty cool to see
and with them facing off against these
guys are basically told by the faceless
man you can't defeat them in the
conventional sense these guys I mean
this place is possessed by by the
spirits of you know countless people so
it's essentially a war of attrition
eventually they'll just be so many that
come at you it'll wear you down and you
won't be able to fight anymore and so in
response to this basically this faceless
man says in order to defeat these guys
you have to travel to a place that's
conducive to your experience it'll give
you basically a reason to keep on going
and so what we end up having is the two
of them traveling to this kind of
in-between version of Wayne Manor and
this is cool
because when they get there Tommy kind
of asked the question why are we here
and dick races responses well because I
Know Who I am but you need to basically
rediscover who you are you're a friend
of Bruce Wayne this is your life and
times more or less you know you're a
friend of Bruce and essentially runs
over all the things that we talked about
earlier but for Nightwing one thing to
also bear in mind here is there is a
little bit of unassured adness thing I
mean you just kind of have to reassure
himself of who he is because while while
Dick Grayson is Nightwing while he does
have Bludhaven he is his own superhero
it's one of those things where like any
normal human being he suffers from an
existential crisis and that's kind of
the question that gets asked like what
am I really doing here like what's the
basis behind all this and that's the
nature of where he's out right now it's
kind of making sure that he really knows
what he's fighting for and what things
mean to him why they're relevant and so
harsh kind of starts laughing you know
Tommy starts laughing a little bit and
we end up finding out that he had used
his surgical skills to turn himself into
Dick Grayson it was kind of like man
because now he's pursuing the life of
Dick Grayson so to speak because in his
mind is no longer a matter of I want to
be Bruce Wayne it's a matter of why did
Bruce take you over me like why did he
choose you instead of me and so when
these people start descending on them
you know when these kind of you know
ghostly folks started ascending on them
basically the door opens up again Batman
saves Dick Grayson dick tries to save
Tommy and it doesn't work so Tommy's
basically left behind presumably to
become one of the mindless ones now this
can go a couple different directions in
reality as cool as as Tommy is as cool
as tush is he's very much a holdover
from before new 52 DC tried to kind of
bring him back in Batman eternal and it
worked for what it was but he's one of
those sort of satellite characters work
you don't see him nearly as much as you
see Joker or penguin or Riddler or
anything like that just because of the
fact that the stories he pops up in are
usually significant I think that Tommy's
a character that DC kind of seems to be
getting rid of that kind of seems to be
the direction that they're going in
because really with this whole thing a
Batman marrying Catwoman
segues into what's supposed to be this
post Doomsday Clock landscape where the
entire dc-dc roster is kind of
reshuffled shaking up and it's kind of
rebirth 2.0 in the sense that rebirth
sort of stops becoming the branding
initiative and we move into the next
phase quote-unquote and so with that in
mind it may just be there's really no
room for hush or he'll show up somewhere
along the line he's very much like Bane
in that capacity but following this you
know where Superman basically takes his
leave it's really just Batman and Dick
Grayson who are left there and this is
awesome the way this is done because if
you go and read Detective Comics or you
go and read the Batman comics or
Nightwing comics they never really cross
over and that was a big thing that
happened in the beginning of rebirth
there was one of the big criticisms
people had was that why doesn't Batman
just call a person in and if he doesn't
then what were they doing at the time
and so that's why if you go and you pick
up the DC we worth do you worth one of
comics you can literally read them all
in chronological order so you see what
Superman was doing between this story
and that story and it fits in perfect
the way that it's done the way it all
lines up and so because of all that neo
dick Grayson's been in Bludhaven dealing
with with everything that's been going
on you know dealing with his girlfriend
and everything that goes on in his own
his own city and so it's kind of cool
because for a lot of fans who are really
a lot of people who were big fans of
Batman one of the things that they
really seem to miss at least of the
various forum poster to be believed as
they missed the the kind of father-son
relationship between Dick Grayson and
Batman now this was the most logical
direction of things where like Dick
Grayson couldn't stay a kid forever and
so because he couldn't stay a kid
forever he'd eventually have to grow up
and step out into his own but it's like
every father and son in the real world
despite the fact that Sun will go off
you'll find a girl he'll eventually
start a family of his own he'll always
return home but you don't really see
that with Dick Grayson in Batman and so
it's really Dick kind of sitting down
you know and in terms of how the story's
written and saying I recognize I haven't
kept contact the way that I should
unless you call us together for some
great big huge crisis I'm nowhere to be
found and that needs to change I want to
play more of a role in your life and I
want to be able to be there outside of
just showing up for various superhero
escapades or some massive crisis I don't
want to put distance between us and so
again it's cool because it's kind of
rekindling this father-son relationship
between Bruce and Dick Grayson and
presumably we're gonna see more
involvement between the two as we go
forward into the future of DC Comics but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain it make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]